- [Voiceover] Hello, everyone, Grant here.
So I'd like to talk to you today
about the various functions of money.
Functions of money.
Now money, of course, is something
that we all use every day
and we kind of have a
general feel for what it is,
but it's interesting to step back
and actually contemplate what is money.
What gives it its value?
What is it that we use it for?
Why is it that you can
use some things for money
throughout history, you
know, people have used
not just gold and silver
but things like salt
or cigarettes as money,
and why other things can't be used.
And economists generally
divide the functions of money,
the things that it does for us
into three different categories.
And sometimes people
add a fourth in there.
I won't get to that in this video,
I'll talk about it in a different one,
but there's kind of three main ones
that people usually talk about.
So if you were an economist,
just kind of philosophizing
about what the functions of money are,
you might start by thinking,
well, what does the world
look like without money?
Like, for example, let's say that you
were a lawyer and you provide
legal counsel to people
and this is the service that you provide
and this is the way you
add value to the economy,
and let's say it's the case
that you're refurnishing
and you want a chair, you
want to go out into the world
and you want to buy a chair.
Well, what that would require
is that you find someone
who happens to produce chairs.
You find some person out there,
and his way of adding value to society
is to produce chairs,
and this is what he does,
and he's specialized at
it and he's very good.
Now the issue here, because
money doesn't exist,
you basically have to trade with him,
you have to barter in some way.
And this is what's
called a barter economy.
And in order to do that,
given that you've specialized in law,
is the thing that you
provide and add value with,
you kind of have to hope
that he wants legal services.
If he happens to be in a situation
where he wants the thing that you provide,
which in this case is legal services,
and if that were true and
you had that good fortune,
then you would be able to trade
some legal services over to him
and he would trade you
some number of chairs,
and all would be well.
But of course, this is kind of rare,
especially given how specialized you are.
And this idea where you want something
and he wants something and
those line up with each other
actually has a name.
This is called the double
coincidence of wants.
Double coincidence, and
it's worth writing down
because people kind of reference this
when we're talking about
barter economies of wants.
And by barter economy I just mean
you know, this kind of set-up,
but scaled up to the scale of society
where everybody's trading
based on their specialty
and what someone else needs.
And in a world of money this seems absurd,
because in reality what you do,
is you would be over here,
and sure you would provide
your legal services,
you'd kind of provide
legal services to someone
as your way of adding value,
but it would be for just
anyone who wants it,
not based on what they produce,
and in response, in exchange for that,
they give you cash, they
just give you money,
something that you can then use,
that everybody accepts for
whatever it is that you want.
So in this case, if you want chairs,
then you bring it over to
the guy who produces chairs
and that's what he gives
you, you know, a chair.
And in so far as money
serves this function,
where it is kind of the
universal thing to trade,
it's called a medium of
exchange, medium of exchange.
And what that means is anytime
that you want to exchange
for something, this is
the common thing of value
that you use to actually
trade with the world.
But that's not the only thing money does.
That's a really big part,
that kind of allows the
entire economy to exist,
and it allows you to specialize
in something like legal services.
But what else does money do?
What else would be harder to
do in a world without money?
Let's say you produce, as a lawyer,
you know, producing legal services,
a little bit more that you
actually wanted to consume,
and you're hoping to kind
of save up some value,
so that maybe later on
you can buy a house,
or you can pay for your kid's education
or something like that.
You want to actually start
storing value and saving it up.
Well, in this barter economy,
you would have to find something,
since money doesn't exist,
you would have to find something of value
and start storing that.
Maybe, you know, chairs
might hold their value
so you're hoping to store them
or maybe you have to buy land or something
that you think will store it,
but there's not kind of
a good de facto medium
that you can do it for.
So in this sense, since that's something
that we usually do with money,
it's also called a good store of value.
So this is considered kind
of a second use of money,
store of value, distinct
from a medium of exchange,
because the idea of needing
something to trade with
is pretty different from
wanting to kind of save value.
And for this third function,
think back to this case
where you're hoping to barter
legal services for chairs.
I mean, once you start
getting into the specifics,
you can start asking the question,
well, actually, how many
hours of legal services
correspond to one chair?
And if you want to buy
something different,
you're going grocery shopping,
how many hours of legal services
corresponds to buying one apple?
And similarly the chair guy,
he has to go off and every
time he's gonna buy an apple,
he has to think how many
chairs correspond to an apple?
And trying to relate values like this
starts getting really complicated
unless you just have some kind
of actual unit to deal with,
something that you can use
to actually measure value
of everything, like a yardstick for value.
And of course in the real economy,
we just give everything a
dollar value, or a euro value,
or a peso value, depending
on where you are,
but you give it a value that
corresponds to the currency,
to the money that you're dealing with.
So people will say money
serves as a unit of value,
a unit of value, and basically that means
that it gives you the starting number,
it gives you the meaning of the number one
so that you can say, well
if this is worth one dollar,
then what is worth three dollars?
Or maybe an hour of this lawyer's time
is worth a hundred dollars,
and one of these chairs is worth $50,
and you can start actually
comparing the values
of various different goods that way.
And I actually think this
is a pretty interesting one.
This is the kind of thing
that would be easy to underappreciate
until you realize how important it is
to have something like this.
And in the next video or two
I'm going to talk about
a certain historical case
of hyperinflation in Brazil
where basically what happens
is money loses some of these functions,
and you can see just how much
a society actually breaks down
if what is supposed to be money
stops serving these functions.
So with that, I will see you next video.